hi and welcome to serverless migration
station i'm wesley from google joined by
martin to help you modernize your apps
running on one of our serverless compute
platforms in this and the next migration
module our little friend portal will
take you on a journey to migrate from
app engine memcache to cloud memory
store but
we need to start using memcache first
before we can migrate to memory store so
this video won't feature any migrating
at all
really more non-migration content in a
migration video series oh you caught me
again
yes porter does take users from point a
to point b but we need to first take a
detour to reacquaint folks with app
engine memcache we'll add memcache usage
to the module one flask app engine adb
app then we can migrate it to cloud
memory store next time in module 13.
sounds good where do we start we're
going to begin with the module 1 app the
one we just migrated from web app 2 to
flask and add use of app engine memcache
to it here's a link to that module 1
codelab and video so you can review it
if necessary
that sounds good wes uh now both of
those are in python 2. what about python
3 developers
yeah until fall 2021 you couldn't port
the module 1 flask app to python 3
because it uses app engine bundled
services in this case ndb
once this feature launched python3 users
are now able to access many of those
services which brought users to app
engine we'll cover this new feature in
another video soon but suffices to say
that users can port the module 1 app to
python 3 first
or add memcache like we're going to do
today and then upgrade to python 3.
either way works
sounds good wes
so what are we going to use memcache for
in our sample app i'm glad you asked
because i was just about to get into
that as you know our app creates a new
entity for each page visit because it
only shows the 10 most recent visitors
there's no need to create new visits if
the same user keeps hitting our website
right so we'll just cache the most
recent visits for an hour for the same
user if a new user comes along that will
reset the cache also the cache will
expire after an hour sound good
okay
but i have to be honest i haven't used
app engine memcache in quite a while can
i get my hands dirty and do it myself
while you are showing us on screen
absolutely go grab the module 1 code if
you did the code lab or clone the repo
or download the zip file if you didn't
pause here if you need to do that module
1 is where we'll start if you want to do
this by hand with me now or on your own
time follow the module 12 code lab ready
let's go to the computer now and do this
because it's always good to start from a
working app use gcloud app deploy to
redeploy your module 1 app and ensure it
works before we update it python 3 users
can delete the app engine config.py file
and relax for a bit while python 2
developers install the third-party
libraries into the lib folder with the
pip install command you see on screen
then everyone can use gcloud app deploy
to upload the app to the cloud then
confirm that that module 1 app still
works now we can add some caching to it
before we make changes be aware you
won't see a difference in output
afterwards instead we're just going to
avoid the extra data store calls and see
lower latency with that out of the way
let's start with the imports at the top
all that's needed is to bring in the app
engine memcache library since we're
going to cache for an hour add a
constant for that
register visits querying for the latest
visits to display and other data store
calls stay the same the biggest updates
to the code are in the main application
so visits are determined by a visitor's
ip address along with the user agent in
the original app we create the visit
entity immediately in the update we save
the visitor info first then try to get
the latest visits from the cache if the
cache is empty or it's a new visitor
save this as the newest visit fetch all
the latest visits from datastore and
cache them for an hour in case the same
visitor comes back sooner and that's all
that's necessary to change this app to
add caching to the module 1 app so now
just save and gcloud app deploy to see
our updated app in action again the
output doesn't change but what you
should notice is that page refreshes
will be much quicker
hit your app from another computer or
wait for more than an hour to see that
the app goes back to its original
latency and fetching of the initial data
now before we get back to the main part
of the show we want to acknowledge that
most of the migration effort is directed
to python 2 users to get them to the
latest app engine runtimes
on screen now are the python 2 and 3
versions of the app the differences you
see are what python 2 developers have to
do to port their apps to python 3. this
is an addition to any other python 2-3
migration steps you need to implement
our sample app is simple enough that it
runs on python 2 and 3 without
modification so what you see is how to
access app engine bundle services in
python 3. more details can be found in
the docs link below as well as how to
access these services from job 11 go112
and newer and php 7.
okay now let's go back to the main
presentation
thanks for the tutorial wes
where should i go if i want to
reacquaint myself with app engine mam
cache yeah i'd say start with the
memcache overview page in the docs for
specific details also check out the
memcache reference stocks in python 2 or
in python 3.
cool i'll take a look but can you give
me heads up on what we're doing next
sure martin now that we have apigen
memcache in our app we'll migrate to
cloud memory store in module 13. if you
want to read ahead check out the links
to the migration page as well as the
cloud memory store docs you can also
take a look at the module 13 codelab to
see what we'll discuss in that video of
course there are plenty other migrations
to consider but at the end of this
module 12 you can get off at this
station staying on app engine memcache
or consider that upgrade to cloud memory
store and we look forward to having you
join us for that discussion in module
13. this is wesley on behalf of martin
and porter and we hope to see you at
that next migration station or on
another serverless expedition soon
[Music]
you